nach diesem spot geht es weiter
total scheiße auf weiß gar nicht was ich
ins gesicht oder reisebüro laufwerke
wenn wirklich nicht wo ich mag die
herzliche noch nicht greifen
wir sind nicht ein facebook-freund schön
um was ging meine frisur für total schön
aus ja gerne
am freitag geht 28 zitierten könnt ihr
mich um 2 415 aufgeteilt werden und zwar
bei der neuen welle
da habe ich mit an toren geschauspielert
und mich glaube ich ganz gut geschlagen
also wir gerade gesehen habt
so schlecht war es nicht schaltet ein
nicht vergessen und jetzt geht weiter
mit dem normalen video
viele leute sagen dass youtube kein
beruf sei ich kann diese aussage schon
verstehen denn es gibt die plattform
youtube noch nicht so lange und wir
menschen können uns halt nicht so
schnell an neue sachen gewöhnen aber
nehmen wir mal als beispiel im beruf des
schauspielers ist das wirklich einen
beruf niemand würde das heute noch
wirklich hinterfragen und es gibt sogar
studien für sabine ich mit dem
schauspiel beschäftigen und wenn du
glück habt dann kann es sogar richtig
viel geld damit verdient was macht den
youtube so anders dass keine fette
produktionsfirma dahinter steckt oder
dass man das nicht an einer uni oder
schule lernen kann vielleicht ist der
grund das geld es ist wirklich einfach
es leuten nicht zu können wenn sie ihr
geld damit verdienen dass sie sich vor
eine kamera stellen und über sich selbst
drehen natürlich kannst du den
eigentlich einschlagen und die fiel mit
seinen videos machen und an einer guten
langen karriere auf youtube arbeiten
oder du machst wie die hälfte der
größten mieter über deutschland und
benutzt anblick content um dann am ende
noch mit produktplatzierungen und guten
werbeeinnahmen belohnt zu werden aber es
soll ja nicht um inhalte gehen und ob
wie gut oder schlecht war sondern was
einem beruf einem beruf macht dafür tue
ich das was alle machen wenn sie meinen
ersteres thema sprechen
ich google nach einer definition ein
beruf ist eine tätigkeit die man
dauerhaft ausüben für die man in der
regel eine bestimmte ausbildung gesetzt
und mit der man seinen lebensunterhalt
verdient quelle das internet das heißt
youtuber ist ein beruf
die tätigkeit selbst die viel nicht
gefällt ich bin auch der meinung dass
unterhaltungsbranche nicht gerade die
ähren folgte besonders wenn du so berufe
wie krankenschwester tierarzt oder
pflegerin leben stellt außerdem ist es
sehr ungerecht aufgeteilt wie viel man
in den einzelnen branchen verdient klare
nur ein medizinstudium absolviert hat
und später als zero menschen das leben
retten kann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
verdienen als eine
bäckereifachverkäuferin denn du hast
viel zeit und geld und eine ausbildung
gesteckt und ist jeden tag so einem
großen risiko ausgesetzt und da geht es
darum leben und tod und nicht um
verbrannte brötchen weiche war wirklich
betonen möchte dass kein beruf für eine
funktionierende gesellschaft weniger
wichtig ist als der andere
also wenn du bäckereifachverkäuferin
bist verkauft und viel ich gute brötchen
die morgens den menschen den tag schöner
machen aber sollte man auch viel geld
verdienen wenn man unterhaltung auf
youtube anbietet ganz ehrlich sollte man
nicht aber es ist einfach so jobs im
zusammenhang mit werbung stehen sind gut
bezahlt und das liegt daran dass seine
konsumgesellschaft sind und firmen wie
coca cola und apple auf dem thron sitzen
und sich freuen aber das ist ein ganz
anderes riesen thema bei den hier viel
zu viel know how fehlt um mit euch
darüber zu sprechen ohne auf diesen
internet marktplatz mit faulen tomaten
beworfen zu werden mein fazit ist also
youtuber sein ist ein beruf und web
video künstler auf youtube sind dies
bleibt voller dienst besteht darin euch
zu unterhalt auch wenn für manche
menschen die unterhaltung darin besteht
einen kanal zu abonnieren damit man ihn
regelmäßig sagen kann 'die packe man ihn
findet nimmt man in diesem moment die
dienstleistung an wir machen uns gerade
für euch zur zielscheibe und was ihr
daraus macht ist aus dem sack ich will
meinen teil freue mich mega über meine
community und machen wirklich sehr gerne
videos für euch oder probieren neue
dinge auch und ich spreche sehr gerne
mal überraschen wie jetzt gerade und
sage meine meinung dazu und freue mich
dass es der leute gibt die wie auch
hören möchten und um nochmal richtig sie
zu werden nur wegen euch kann ich so
coole dinge die mit antoine machen und
für eine comedy-serie in einem sketch
mit spielen also danke schön
ich hoffe natürlich hat das video
gefallen und wenn ihr mich bei knaller
kerle gesehen habt dann erzählt mir doch
mal wie ihre meine schauspielkünste
findet und wie ihr die sendung findet
und waffen wünsche ich euch ein
ein schöner leben und bis bald